shout out to the cocoa butter uh you are
a pretty healthy guy in general I would
say right
um
what is your like Diet regimen like
these days
um how do you look young you know what's
crazy with me I don't really have a diet
I just don't eat no pork
so you don't eat the swine no no Swan
stop for law I don't know I stay far
away from that okay I'm Muslim you know
that okay but um
yeah I I stay far away from pork
um I eat a lot of seafood
I love Seafood uh what about red meat
you have a steak I like steaks like if
my moms make it or if we had a flavor
restaurant or some [__] like that I
might order a steak depending on my mood
but I kind of I don't really I don't
over indulge as much as I did in my 20s
in red meat as I do I mean like I fell
back are you doing any vitamins it's
like CMOS or anything um CMOS uh bladder
rack all that um black seed oil bladder
bladder rack what's that mean it's like
a um I hope I'm saying it right big
shout out to Styles P
with the pharmacy I'll take that ride up
you know what I'm saying go up there and
they give me a whole uh like a Christmas
package a healthy [__] for me my kids
you got the he got the the tablets or
the healthy [__] CMOS and all that that
tastes like candy for the kids so me and
my kids I'm big on
I'm just big on health bro and not
getting sick and catching colds and you
know I'm saying like you really can't be
active out here if you if you sneezing
and all that type of [__] did you uh
catch covet when it was running around I
actually did catch it shouts to my
brother doc I don't want to blow that
spot up but I think that [__] doc gave
me Kobe you heard or the mother was it a
rough go
um I just couldn't taste nothing and it
was Thanksgiving oh the worst time
or so my mom's getting busy I couldn't
smell nothing
let's talk about the word that's the
single worst time you could have got
covered no that was terrible bro it was
to the point where like you know when
you taking this [__] you smell your [__]
like well your [__] like you know what's
crazy I couldn't smell my [__] that's
how I knew I had so it had me scared
kind of like you know what I'm saying
you don't know if a joints if you don't
know if breath stinks I could be talking
to you right in your face you don't even
know that like I'm just dugging it out
like what's up bro like yeah my dog took
over this nasty my dog [__] on the floor
and I didn't smell it couldn't smell
nothing and I was like
and that [__] probably was rocking no
right and so I was like
this was like June of 2020 so I'm like
oh [__] I got kovitz that's what I
called it and then I held it up and I
was like oh yeah I don't smell anything
yeah this is crazy I had it for like
nine ten days my best friend died
on May 5th 2020 shooter God bless his
soul you mess shooter I brought him here
and then my daughter was born my second
daughter Kobe my little badass November
11th 2020. so I caught it like right
when she was born type [__] so when I
brought her from the hospital back to
the crib
I think I that's when um
um the ps5s and all that was just coming
out I was slanging it you know me and my
man I had a little homie had him in the
hood
am I called my son dot like yo bro bring
me over here let's get the PS5 for my
little man
when dot pull up he's sweating mine was
like cold outside what's up with you you
drink like now I'm good he coughing and
[__] I'm right man you know I've been
watching the news yeah everyone at that
time yeah there ain't no regular cold
man watch them sneezes and all that [__]
watch your hands watch all that you feel
me come to find out
me and him like Brian go front let's go
to Urgent Care bro me and you like I
feel you got me feeling Wicked already
bro we went over there and I took two
tests they had to um the rapid [__] and
it was negative I was like all right I'm
Gucci and then they did the real one the
[__] that take like 10-15 minutes to
ship when they put it up in your mouth I
went through all that with it they was
putting them shits in your brain they
all went through that hey man we went to
Jamaica they did that [__] they put that
[__] in my in my forehead I'm like yo
this is crazy pause
but
I I caught it but I had it nine ten days
got off and I ain't catch it again I
never got the um you never got jabbed no
if you miss out on any opportunities
because you decided not to be vexed
um
by the way kudos to you I don't think so
not pressuring to the social
pressure of yeah you know what you know
what it is bro by the way I pressure to
it I'm into my mom's and my dad did but
they older so I kind of respected what
they were saying just because they you
know they both 70 years old said now
like if you're like in good health and
you caught it it was better immunity
than the vaccine because then you're
just catching it yeah your body fight it
all gangster that's like any cold like
the flu anything you caught before
anything I caught bro like like chicken
pox you from that area yeah the Chicken
Box kids don't catch that noise you get
it once and it's done but if you
scratched it remember they used to say
especially I see people today got mad
chicken pox because they were scratching
that [__] calamine lotion
anytime you get a bug bite calamine
my mom's used to put us in the bath and
and Lace Us in Calamine you know what I
never use with Calamine I never use
Calamine with the porn like I did the
cocoa butter yeah I hope the [__] not
man yeah that's good
all right